abone ol
mi Evet ben Siber güvenlik kariyerime 20
yıl önce genç ve heyecanlı bir genel
müdürü olarak başladı genel müziğime Bak
ben asla o zamanlar Siber güvenlik öyle
çok da bilinen umursayan bir Konu
başlığı değil hatta Annem biraz da
endişeli dedik oğlum sen şimdi hadi
kartları mı genel müdür oluyorsun
tehlikeli mi bu yapacağın işte ben
moralimi bozmadım biraz da herhalde
Hollywood'un da etkisiyle dedim ki Siber
badigart Siber Kahraman kızlar boyanacak
ama o günden bugüne gördü benim
Kariyerim pek de bunun ilerisine
açıkçası gitmedi diye gördüm ki Siber
güvenlik uzmanı olmak öyle çok da kolay
bir şey değil hep uyanık olmamız
gerekiyor birazparanoyak olmaz hiç
kimseye güvenmem miyiz Hatta yüzdeyüz
Güvenliğiniz diyecek şekilde kendinize
bile güvenmeniz gerekiyor çünkü aşırı
Özgüven sizi çok komik durumlara ne
yazık ki düşürebiliyor evet dünyanın
Sibel
bu anlamındaki aşırı özgüveni bugün
Siber suçun dünyaya maliyetine 3 trilyon
dolara kadar çıkarmış durumda bunun daha
da fazla yükselmesini istemiyorsak bence
teknoloji tarihinden çok iyi şekilde
öğrenmeliyiz bunu incelemeliyiz Çünkü bu
suç tarih boyunca hep teknolojiyi takip
etti ve bundan Sonrasında da inanın hep
böyle olacak bakın 50 yıl önce colnbrook
ve Ekibi internetin atası olan arpanet
teno ilk kelime yolladığını hayatınız
inanılmaz şekilde değiştikten sadece iki
yıl sonra ilk virüsle tanıştık Creeper
bunun hemen arkasından bugün internetin
50 katına kadar büyümüş olan suçların
interneti de diyebileceğiniz dart Metin
1972'de tohumları atıldı mı emaneti ve
Center öğrencileri arpanet üzerinden ilk
uyuşturucu ticaretini gerçekleştirdiler
2000'e kadar pek çok kolay oldu yüzle
Ya aslında Sakin geçti demek mümkün
bununla beraber yine bir teknoloji
oluyor yani internetin sadece beş yıl
İçerisi 16 milyon kişiler 2 bin 350
milyon kişiye büyümesiyle beraber Siber
suçlarda Patlamaya başladı Yani Milenyum
sadece bizim için değil suçlar içinde
bir kutlama olacaktı sahneyi tarihin en
güzel birisiyle açtılar Anna kournikova
büyüsü Anna'nın çıplak resimleri olduğu
zannedilen bir dosyayı açmak için
Milyonlar yarıştı büyük ihtimalle de
erkekler Hadi virüs olduğunu bilenler
bile abiye değilse gibi bir heyecanla
dosyayı açmaya çalıştılar
bu yıllar içerisinde gördüğünüz güvenlik
ve tek şey güvenliğin tek değişmeli
insanın zincirin zayıf halkası olması
oldu çünkü insanı kandırmak ne yazık ki
çok kolay Peki Sizler de hatırlarsınız
Nijeryalı prensten gelen mailleri
haciomerler vardı ya Sevgili kardeşim
devrik Kral babamın 30 milyon doların
ülkeden çıkarma yardım edersen bu parayı
seninle paylaşmak istiyorum Bana bin
dolar gönderirsen falan diye devam eden
millerden bahsediyorum bakın 20 yıl
boyunca yedik tarihe geçtin ticari
Krallık bile değil Bunu bile umursamadı
ben öyle bir Güven yaratmıştı ki
prensesler uzun zamandır ses çıkmadı
acaba başına bir şey mi geldi diyenler
bile oldu öyle biri ortalama saldırılır
dediğimiz ve yüzlercesini binlercesini
yaşadığımız bu saldırılar zaman
içerisinde tüm salgının yüzde doksanı
üçünü oluşturacaklar hepsinin tek bir
ortak tarafı vardı aciliyet ve heyecan
yaratmak düşünmeden
bu harekete geçmesine neden olmak ve
bunu da muhteşem bir şekilde başardılar
tarih boyunca yıllar içerisinde ortalama
saldırıları da evrildi hackerların
kurbanları oy verenlere tıkladıkları
zaman bilgisayarlarını kitledikleri ve
fidye ödedikleri saldırılar yani
ransomware saldırıları dünyayı sarsmaya
başladı böyle muhteşem taktikler
kullanıyorlardı ki hani o iş dünyası
promosyon taktikleriyle on arkadaşına
yolla fidye ödeme falan gibi sistemler
bile kurmuşlardı bununla beraber
hacker'lar ödemeleri Bitcoin olarak
alıyorlardı Bitcoin paranın dışarıya
çıkarılması ile izin kaybettiğiniz
konusunda hackerın en büyük yardımcısı
olmuştu Hatta tarihimizdeki en büyük
Sanal Para hırsızlığı 531 milyon
dolarlık koyun çek saldırısında
Saniyeler içerisinde paranın izini
kaybettirdiler Kağıt parayla mümkün
olmayacak şekilde
Ben 10 dolarlık banknotların A bu elli
ton ağırlığında olacaktı
bu ve öğrendik ev bazıları gerçekten de
sadece antivirüs sil gelişmiş internet
güvenliği yazılımları kullanmamız lazım
dedi bununla beraber bununla da
yetinmediler eğer kar istedikleri yani
bunda bir gariplik var dedikleri bir
takım meyveleri aldılarsa Bunu sen aç
gibi virustotal gibi rapte şu motor gibi
birtakım hep sitelerinden önce
tıklamadan önce kontrol ettiler bununla
beraber Her ihtimale karşı diyor
muhakkak bilgilerin ve kaplarını almaya
devam ediyorlar Bazıları için ise hiçbir
önlem almadı ve video ödemeyi tercih
bu 2005'te beraber 100 milyona Varan
kimlik hırsızlıklarını yaşamaya başladık
çok iyi oluyorduk güvenliğinde en
tepesine oturdu problemler açıkçası o
zamanlar yıllar içerisinde yüzlerce
bunun benzeri saldırı yaşayacağımızı Ya
bunun 2013'te 3 milyar kişilik tarihi
bir rekorla 3 milyar kişinin
database.ini saldıracağını 2016'da da
tarihin en korkulan saldırısını
yaşayacağımızı tahmin etmemiştik ve
tarihin en korkulan saldırısı
bu dünyanın en büyük zeytin websitesi
Eda lütfen Finder ınpec edilmesi ve 412
milyon kişinin isimlerinin açığa
çıkmasını büyük panik yarattı büyük yani
internetin yüzde onu Eda lütfen fine
üyesiymiş tahmin ediyor musunuz tek
güzel taraf vardı Hiç kimse kimseye
Vedat Abi sen de mi ya ayıp diyemedi
Hani herkes orada yani Bu odadakiler
hariç demek istiyorum
var Bununla beraber sadece kimlikler
çalınmadı perspektifler açalım bunlarda
aktifte satılmaya başladı ama
milyarlarca perfore satılıyor şu anda
daha net de bunlardan gördüğümüz
insanlar başlarına ne gelirse gelsin
dünyanın en çok kullanılan personelleri
herzaman en basit olanları 123456 ve
Passport ve bunu da bütün hesaplarımıza
da kullanıyoruz ve bu şu anda dünyanın
en büyük saldırıları dahil olmak üzere
toplam saldırıların Yüzde altmış günde
bir zafiyet noktası yani saldırı noktası
olarak karşımıza çıkıyor yazık bugün
gerçekten de 12 karakterli üstü içinde
ASKİ karakterler olan büyük harf küçük
harf sayılarını olduğu personelleri
kullanmaya ihtiyacımız var ama bunları
hatırlamak gerçekten de neredeyse
imkansız Bu yüzden de Diyoruz ki
pasaportlar öldü Yaşasın pas prizler
diyeceksiniz ki bu da ne ola bugün sizin
için bir tane hazırladım bakın
bu peki böyle bir pas prizi nasıl
kolaylıkla hatırlarsınız tabi sizden bir
hikayeden alındıysa
Selam bugün tetikte sizlerle beraber
olmak gerçekten çok güzel nokta gerekli
düzeltmeleri de yapalım ufak Tamam artık
pessimis hazır bakın kırılması 857
milyar yıl sürecek bu kadar zamana
ihtiyacım yok Çünkü hesapları önem
derecesine göre birileri üç ay arasında
bunların tamamını değiştirmem gerekiyor
ne öğrendik bazıları pas faizleri
kullanmaya başladılar Ben sözleri kısa
aralıklarla değiştirdiler farklı farklı
hesaplarda aynı personelleri
kullanmadılar mümkün olan her yerde iki
faktörlü kimlik doğrulamayı kullanılar
bazıları ise Avrupa Sovyetler zor ya
dediler ama bu pek edilmeden önceki son
sözler oldu Hep ne yazık bakın 2007'de
Nihayet güzel bir şey oldu jops bize
hayatımızı cebimize koymaya söz verdi ve
sözünü de tut tut bu küçük cihaz
inanılmaz şekilde hayatımızı
değiştirecek hayatımızdaki en büyük
Ben yarın daha da aptallaşma sına neden
olacaktır
var Bununla beraber üç arkadaşla beraber
yola çıktılar ve tarihin en büyük
dönüşümünü başlattılar Artık her şey
dijital olmuştu iki şey istemeye
başladık daha fazla like almak ve her an
her yerde anında online onu ama biz İşe
rasyonlar açıkçası online olmak için
çektiğimiz bu acı hiçbir zaman unutmadık
ne olacak şey
bu İlhan abi bağlandık abi Tabii ki
Ekinler da bu gelişmeleri takip ettiler
insanlar sosyal medyada ilgilerini
paylaşmak için yarışırken onlar da Büyük
bir keyifle o bilgileri insanları
kurbanların profil yemek için
kullanıyorlar ve kişiye özel
spearfishing dediğimiz kişiye özel
saldırılarını geliştirmeye başladılar
çok daha tehlikeli hale gelmeye başlamış
saldırır Evet bazıları sosyal medyada
bilgileri paylaşırken daha dikkatli
davranmaya başladı ama yine de artık bu
bir yeni Normalde her şey dijital bakın
çocuklar bile Noel Baba'dan hediye
isterken Amazon yuvar ellerini
kullanıyorlar dilenciler nakitsiz çuval
koduyla dilenmeye başlamışlar böyle bir
dünyadan bahsediyorum Bu da yetmedi
dünyayı daha da güzelleştirmek için
yepyeni bir tür yaratmaya karar verdik
dünya güzelleştirme görevi sadece
robotlara ver
bu Aynı zamanda da ayoti cihazı
dediğimiz o akıllı cihazlara verdi hemde
milyonlarcası artık uçaklar arabalar dev
ayoti cihazlarına dönüşmüş lerdi ve
bunlar dev software yıllarına dönüşleri
ortak yanları hepsi yapay zeka ile
donatılmış bununla beraber inanılmaz
büyüklükteki detayla besleniyorlar
problem hemen hemen hepsi korumasız the
Bu gerçekten de kritik konuya dikkat
çekmek son derece önemlidir ve beyaz
şapkalı hacker lar yani İyiler ilk defa
Belki de kötülerden önce davrandılar
Bari ilk olarak pales eklemidir arabayı
hareket Cherokee nin top tüm kontrolünü
ele geçirmişlerdi gaz fren direksiyon
onun arkasından Chris Roberts uçağı
hareket hemen sonrasında gemi hemen
sonrasında treni hızını alamayıp nasıl
Uzay İstasyonu bile et amaç ortaktı
bu işlerin düzelmesi bişeylerin
değişmesi bu önlemlerin alınmaya
başlanması gerekiyordu çünkü artık bu
insan ölümüyle sonuçlanabilecek çok
tehlikeli bir saldırıya dönüşmüştü bakın
bugün şöyle bir senaryoyla ne yazık ki
karşılaşmak mümkün
bu işinizin aracı pek edildi hacker'lar
tüm kontrolü ele geçirdiler ve ölümden
kurtarmanız için sizden fidye istiyorlar
ve şöyle bir sesli mesaj aldınız
sevgilim kurban ol
bu yanlış olduğunu Anlamak istemiyorsan
önündeki içinde sana yollayacağım sabah
11 koyuyorlar ararsın
Ama tabi karar olarak Abi ben 20 vereyim
sen devam et de diyebilirsiniz ama o
Tabii ki sizin kararınız ve internette
Gerçekten de şu anda çok büyük bir savaş
devam ediyor bakın saatten önce
kaydedilmiş hackerların dünyada nereden
nereye saldırdığını gösteren gerçek bir
harita
ve on binlerce hacker şu anda tüm
dünyaya saldırıyorlar ülkelerin Siber
orduları birbirlerine saldırıyorlar dost
ülkeler bile korkmalımıyız eğer farklı
davranmamız A neden olacaksa Hayır eğer
paralizi olup ben ne yapabilirim ki
diyeceksiniz Çünkü farkı yaratacak olan
sizsiniz gerçekten de sizsiniz çünkü
hacker'lar yıllardır sadece size defa
almış durumdalar güvenlik artık bir
teknolojik problem değil bir tercih
problemi hacker'lar sizi kandırmaya
çalışıyorlar bilgisayarlarınızı değil
bakın dünyanın en tehlikeli haklarından
biri olarak kabul edilen Red şansın bir
konferansımız da yaptığımız söyleşide
şöyle dedi
bu hacker'lar bilgisayarları değil
arkasında oturan insanları pek ederler
gerçekten de içinde bulunduğumuz durumu
çok güzel bir şekilde özetliyor ve Bence
artık güvenli olmayı tercih etmenin
zamanı gelmiş durumda Çünkü artık sadece
fiziksel değil aynı zamanda bir de
dijital hayata sahip ses ve bunu da çok
önemsiyor ve sadece bizim değil çok
küçük yaşlardan beraber o yaşlarla
beraber çocuklarımız da böyle bir hayata
sahip oluyorlar ve ne yazık ki bizim
maruz kaldığımız tehditlere onlarda
maruz kalıyorlar Hatta belki de bizden
bile daha önce Çünkü teknolojileri hep
bizdende daha önce kullanmaya
başlıyorlar
bu yeni dünyada Siber güvenliğin bazı
kuralları var
Az önce sola sonra sağa sonra tekrar
sola bakmak ve İşlek bir caddede bunu
yapmazsanız edilebileceğini bilmek gibi
basit ama Hayati kurallardan
bahsediyorum bakın Biz evimizde yıllar
önce güvenli internet için ailemizin 10
kuralı posterini duvarlara astık üzerine
pek çok sohbet gerçekleştirdik yeri
geldi birbirimizi intihar ettik sokakta
olduğu gibi internette güvenliği de
hayatımızın bir parçası yapmaya çalıştık
Hala da Çalışmaya devam ediyoruz çünkü
dijital dünyada Siber güvenlik bir yaşam
şekli olmalı tabii ki dozunu Fazla
kaçırmadan
bu ve artık çok iyi biliyoruz ki
masumiyet şu anda yaşamıyoruz yine çok
iyi biliyoruz ki abi nereden geldi Nasıl
oldu bir Anadolu'da anlayamadım deme
lüksüne Sahip değiliz çünkü bu
tehditlerle 50 yıldır beraber yaşıyoruz
Ama ben de çok iyi biliyorum ki 18
dakikada Bütün internet güvenliği
problemlerinize çözüm getirme mümkün
olmadı ama malum değişmek farklı
davranmak için karar vermek 18 saniye
bile değil o yüzden sizden tek ricam hiç
kimseden beklemeyin çocuklarımıza
güvenli bir dijital gelecek vermek için
değişim siz olun
bu ve lütfen ertelemeyin Çünkü bu
değişimi başlatmak için en muhteşem Gül
bugün sağlık